بين حسابات الربح والخساره تشتد حده
التنافس بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين فكل
صوت اصبح له حساباته وكل تقدم لاي من
الحزبين يعني الكثيره في مسيرتهما
الصناديق لم تحقق حتى الان امال
الجمهوريين مبدا احمر كما كان متوقعا حيث
بدى السباق متكافئا نوعا ما وبفوارق ضئيله
النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات النصفيه حمل
التحديا لموقع الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كشخصيه مهيمنه في الحزب الجمهوري تسعى
للعوده لتصدر المشهد او الترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه ابعد من ذلك
بعض مستشار ترامب اعتبرون نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه جرحا لمستقبله السياسي
بحسب تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست كما شجعوه
على تاجيل اعلان ترشحه للرئاسه لما بعد
تحديد الاغل التي في مجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
في المقابل
يجلس على مقعد قد يفقده عام 2024 تحيط به
قضايا شائكه من ارتفاع التضخم الدائن
انخفاض اعداد الموافقين عليه وهو انخفاض
فرض تساؤلا من العديد من النقاد بحسب فقس
نيوز عما اذا كانت ديمقراطيون سيرشحون
الرئيس السادس والاربعين للسباق الرئاسي
لعام 2004
ايجار بدون حساب الانتخابات النصفيه يرتبط
بنتائج الصناديق المعلقه اما التوقعات فلا
مكان لها على ما يبدو عصام عبد السلام
العربيه